hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast can CAD drive GPCR drug
design rapid estimation of relative
binding affinities based on pre computed
ensembles presented by Alexander Macau
PhD Roman glint professor of our
reciprocal Sciences director
computer-aided drug design Center
University Maryland School of Pharmacy I
am Christine mahalik of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's
events we are delighted to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots libraries is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the top down box that
appears on the screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use an ask a question box and
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the accreditation button
located in the promotional board at the
bottom center of your screen and follow
the process to obtain your credits
please join me in welcoming dr. McCrae I
will now turn the presentation over to
have
all right hello everyone thank you for
joining us today
and I will give you an overview of the
methodologies that we've developed in
the lab to facilitate computer aided
drug design and how we've extended those
methodologies to be useful for g-protein
coupled receptors GPCRs before I can
start my talk I have to give you my
speaker disclosure form is required by
the University one of the areas that I'm
interested in is entrepreneurial
activity we have a company soaps bio LLC
which is marketing the technologies that
are presenting today we then do other
work with the University of Maryland
different thumb societies in the area of
drug design and so on
now computer-aided drug design
computer-aided drug design can be used
for the qualitative mode and a
quantitative mode qualitatively the
scientist just wants to get an idea of
what types of modifications of a
compound can lead to improved biological
activity improved affinity approved
specificity proof bioavailability and
for a synthetic and medicinal chemist at
the same time they're thinking about how
to change the structure of the drug they
can be thinking about how to actually
synthesize that drug cad methods can
also be used in a quantitative format
where you actually want to make
predictions of linking to fitted
affinity Willet modifications need to
improve binding improved affinity
improved bioavailability and we want to
be able to make those quantitative
evaluations in a fashion that will lead
to drug design process and one thinks in
terms of a medicinal chemistry program
in an industrial setting typically 100
or more compounds can be synthesized and
tested per week accordingly the cad
methodologies need to evaluate about 10
times as many compounds so therefore our
cad technologies need to be able to go
through thousands of compounds on a
weekly basis and the methodologies we've
developed allow us to do that and the
methodologies are both useful
qualitatively especially the silks
methodology that i'll introduce and then
quantitatively to allow us to make
predictions of the changes infinity for
literally thousands of compounds on a
weekly basis now the foundation for the
cad technologies that we use in what's
called molecular dynamics simulations
molecular dynamics simulations are tools
that basically allow for molecules to
move in a computer we can take the
position two molecules we can calculate
the forces acting on those molecules and
then they start to move and once we
start to move we can use the motion
combined with other equations to
estimate the free energies of binding
the changes in the free energies of
binding and then also those motions
allow us to generate in Sambas of
confirmations we then facilitate the
actual calculation of the binding free
energies so we'll talk about molecular
dynamics simulations but in simple terms
we're basically allowing four molecules
to move in the computer much the same
way that they move in the real world now
for quantitative cad we want to be able
to determine the absolute binding
affinity for protein ligand complex or
the relative affinity now to calculate
the absolute binding affinity we
actually have to calculate the
equilibrium between the protein ligand
complex and the protein alone in
solution and we can do this with
molecular dynamics simulations but it's
very expensive these are very long
simulations which would take days weeks
or months and we need to do that for
every new widget every time we change
the structure the ligand we have to go
back and we do this huge calculation now
one of the ways that we can get around
this is determining
change in the binding free energy our
delta delta j and we can do that in what
we call free energy perturbation but
what we're doing is we're actually
perturbing the structure of the molecule
from lead compound one so you adding a
methyl group or a city group to make
compound two and then we calculate the
free energy difference associated with
that chemical perturbation so instead of
calculating the absolute binding
affinity we calculate the free energy
difference in this calculation is much
faster however it's still relatively
slow allowing the calculation of about
maybe ten perturbations per day on a
typical computer cluster that the
company has now key to the calculation
of this free energy difference Delta
Delta G is this the need for an in samba
love confirmations which are indicated
by these angular brackets so basically
with both the absolute free energy of
binding calculation as well as with the
change in the free energy of binding
Delta Delta G the key component is
getting this in Samba love confirmations
and that is very expensive
computationally so we want to be able to
get around that so we can do our drug
design in a quantitative fashion much
more rapidly so what we're going to do
that our methodologies is we're going to
pre compute these conformational and
samples once we pre compute this
conformation ensembles we can calculate
the change in the binding infinity Delta
Delta G very rapidly for many many
chemical modifications of the compounds
so we're going to do one expensive
calculation upfront which will take an
order of 12 hours up until a week or two
depending on the method and the size of
the protein but then once we've got that
pre computed in Samba we can use it very
rapidly to estimate the change in the
binding affinity of hundreds or
thousands of modifications of our
compound and the two methodologies that
I'm going to talk about today are one is
single step free energy perturbation
SSF EP and the second is site
identification by linking competitive
saturation or silks majority the talk
will talk about the silks methodology as
this is useful for both qualitative and
quantitative drug design though we will
initially introduce the SS MVP
methodology as well as later in the talk
show an example of it using the concept
of in the context of gpcrs finally I'd
like to introduce what we call the charm
general force field and its associated
program which is important because in
the computer we have to create all of
the molecules and when you're doing
computer aided drug design you have to
rapidly create the information
associated with the hundreds of
thousands of different chemical
structures you want to work with and the
C gen FF program allows us to do that
it's a very important component of our
CAD methodologies which works in
conjunction with the SSF vp or the silks
technologies okay so now single step
strategy perturbation now in single step
fantasy perturbation we go in and we do
our pre computation which is performing
an MD simulation on our lead compound
protein complex we also do this
pre-computation on the lead compound in
solution alone once you've done this
computation we can then apply the pre
computed example to calculate the change
in the binding of a ligand hundreds of
thousands of times associated with
different modifications of that leggett
and we do this because in the context
what we call the exponential formalism
which is used in the free energy
perturbation methodology so our pre
compute MD simulation depending on the
CPU resources and the type of protein
you're using typically takes in the
order of 12 hours then once we have that
pre computed MD in Samba we can then
calculate our change in the free energy
of binding about 10 CPU minutes per
modification and one thinks about it you
have
computer cluster which has say 50 or 100
individual CPUs you can see how quickly
you can get in a matter of hours
thousands of modifications and this is
the power of the approaches pre
computing the conformational and soluble
and then doing large numbers of
perturbations for chemical modifications
and then understanding the free energy
difference so again just to sort of
reiterate in this slide is we're going
to take a protein ligand complex we're
going to do an env simulation and we're
going to save the structures from that
energy simulation we call these the
coordinates we're going to do the same
for our ligand in solution and then once
we have this collection of coordinates
this conformational ensemble we're then
going to go in and build modifications
onto the parent ligand and then rapidly
understand the change in the free energy
of binding of the ligand by doing this
calculation which we show in the
equations at the bottom of the slide we
calculate the energy of the unmodified
ligand l0 the energy of the modified
ligand l1 many many times for all the
different coordinates that's all the
different confirmations in the ensemble
we're going to apply the exponential
form formula which we see there are two
log and then we see our angular brackets
to get the free energy difference in the
presence of the enzyme or protein as
well as in water alone and then we take
the difference in the free energy in the
presence of the protein subtract that in
for the ligand in water alone and then
we get the change in the binding
affinity and again we can do this quite
quickly and we can do it for large
numbers of modifications quite rapidly
and the next couple slides I'm going to
just show you some validation and then
later in the talk I'll show you an
example we use SFS SFTP in the context
of GPCRs and when we initially developed
a methodology we wanted to make sure
that we could calculate the relative
binding of hydration free energy this is
the energy of putting a molecule
lucien of benzene analogs and this would
be analogous to modifying a drug like
molecule and understanding how its
salvation energy changes this is
information that can be used for say
bioavailability and so on and what you
simply see in the two plots is a nice
correlation between the Delta Delta G
values from our SSS VP method on the
y-axis and then the Delta Delta G values
measured experimentally on the x-axis or
via a much more expensive fancy
perturbation methodology called
thermodynamic integration on the right
panel below and it's just validating the
methodology in the next slide we also
validate the methodology in the context
of the relative binding affinity of a
series of inhibitors of the protein
thrombin again you can see that the
correlation between Delta Delta G's for
the SSSP method and the experimental
values are quite good giving us a
predictive index of about point six
point seven which is indicating that the
quantitative information predicting
which modifications will increase the
binding affinity versus decrease of bond
affinity is quite good therefore this is
the type of information we want to get
out of this methodology ok we'll now
jump over to the silks methodology to
cite identification by linking
competitive saturation and in this
methodology the what we're doing is
we're calculating the functional group
affinity pattern of the entire
three-dimensional space in and around a
protein this is done using a combination
of MD simulations with the methodology
we call grand canonical Monte Carlo and
I'll introduce that a little bit later
and in this methodology we include
protein flexibility we include explicit
solvent this is means the actual water
molecules of presence and then we
actually include explicit solutes which
are representative of the different
types of functional groups so we do is
we do this these long GC mcmd
simulations from which we obtain
or precomputed and samba love
confirmations which allows us to
calculate what we call fried maps which
I'll need to do shortly which you can
then use for both quantitative and
qualitative ligand design and we'll go
through the details of how those are
used and so on now English sales
methodology what we're doing is again
we're doing this all in computer and if
you take you sit to the left if you take
a box of water which we can have in a
computer and we say we add a benzene
molecule and we do our mines in the
dynamic simulation that benzene molecule
will diffuse all throughout the
simulation box we can then calculate the
probability of the benzene being in any
pixel in our simulation system and
because it's only water in benzene the
benzene distribution will be the same
anywhere and which we sort of
color-coded distribution the colors
obviously the same throughout the entire
box it's a homogeneous probability
distribution now we want to understand
what's happening the presence of the
protein so we see to the right where we
add a little protein to our simulation
system we then do our molecular dynamics
simulation the proteins moving the
benzene moving the water molecules are
moving and when you now calculate the
probability distribution of the benzene
if there's a pocket on the protein
surface with a benzene favorably binds
you'll have a much higher probability we
sit we see that in red or others reasons
where the benzene doesn't like to bind
or cannot overlap with the protein we
see a much lower probability and we see
those as lighter colors white now what
we do is we take the probability
distribution in the presence of the
protein we normalize it divide that by
the probability distribution in the
actions of the protein and we end up
with this normalized probability
distribution which we see to the lower
right where we have a probability of one
out in solution saying there's the
energy the probability of the molecule
being in solution this is this is equal
to if there was no protein there at all
we have higher probability regions where
the solute in this case benzene wants to
spend
a lot of time and then we have the lower
probability reasons where I want to
spend much less time much less than
being actually in solution alone these
are unfavorable reasons so this
probability distribution can now go from
looking at it in two dimensions we're
all really going to start to convert it
to three dimensions where we can now
actually look at the distribution of
different functional groups in and
around the protein and we'll start to
look into that more detail now in
practice
we don't have just one solute molecule
or benzene for example in our simulation
system but we have up to eight and here
you're seeing an example of eight solute
molecules representing different types
of functional groups we see benzene
which is aromatic propane which is
aliphatic we've got formamide
which is representative bond acceptors
and donors we've methanol which is an
alcohol we have acid out of hi which is
another type of acceptor we have emitted
all which is an example of a heterocycle
hydrogen with a hydrogen bond donor and
acceptor we have a negatively charged
acetate then a positively charged methyl
ammonium so this mixture of solutes
represents all the different types of
functional groups that we typically see
hydrogen bond donors hydrogen bond
acceptor hydrophobic groups and then
charged groups and so on and we take
this mixture we put it into a solution
with our protein and then we do a
collection of these GCM C and D
simulations and this is our pre computed
in soluble from which we're going to get
what we ultimately call our fragment
maps and I'll introduce those at a
moment in addition to the solutes that
I'm showing this slide we can also have
a collection of solutes which say
includes different
halogens chlorobenzene bromobenzene
fluorobenzene
tri fluoro ethylene and so on
so we can have halogen frag maps but
halogens are known to exist in a large
percentage of excuse me drugs and they
accordingly are ventures to drug design
so we can have these halogen fragment
maps and use those and so on
okay so basically what I'm showing here
is the actual MD simulation of a protein
it's in a box of water you see the water
molecules are shown in red and then we
have our different solutes which are
floating around in there you can see the
different signs floating around in
surrounded by the water molecules
basically this is our pre-computation
we're doing these MD simulations and
what we then do is we put the system
into a grid and we calculate the
probability of the different types of
science the different types of
functional groups being in the different
grid points I'm showing this in two
dimensions but once we we actually have
a protein surrounded by water in three
dimensions and this ultimately leads us
allows us to calculate the
three-dimensional probability
distributions for the different types of
functional groups in and around the
entire protein I'm showing those
probability distributions to the right
overlaid on the protein on which we were
doing the MU simulation this is sort of
the basis of the silks technology is
this pre-computation from which we get
these fried mats these functional group
probability distributions and we can now
use these fragments most quality both
qualitatively to visualize where we want
different types of functional groups as
well as quantitatively to estimate the
change in the binding affinity of
different links and I'll follow up on
this in the next few slides looking a
little bit more closely we're looking
now at the example of frag maps on p38
MAP kinase and what you see here are the
different types of fragment maps they
encompass the entire protein in this
case the p38 MAP kinase we can see how
the center of the protein is the binding
site that we're interested in but what
you see now is you see the different
fragments in different types of regions
telling us where we would like to have
say hydrogen bond acceptor hydrogen bond
donors aliphatic groups aromatic groups
and so on so this is again the basic
information that we get from these silks
pre-computation and then once we've got
this information
we can use this over and over again for
any ligand that we're looking at and so
on now we're going to focus in on the
binding site of the p38 MAP kinase and
we've now overlaid an inhibitor of the
protein from a crystal structure on to
the maps now if you look at this figure
what you see here is the binding site we
see the sovereign accessibility of the
protein associated with the crystal
structure and then we see the different
fragment maps if you look at the
fragment maps up to the right we see
these aliphatic and aromatic fragment
maps and they're hydrophobic groups so
they correspond with each other
interestingly in the center then we also
see a hydrogen bond acceptor map this is
indicating that in this region we could
add other aliphatic groups aromatic
groups or hydrogen bond acceptor to a
molecule to potentially improve the
binding also what you see here is the
maps actually penetrate underneath the
surface of the protein this is important
because in these MD simulations were
allowing the protein to move so we can
actually understand how the protein
structure can open you can change its
conformation to allow for leggings to
bind and this is important because we're
doing our drug design process we're no
longer just limited by the surface of
the protein from the crystal structure
but we can start to think in terms of
the way that the protein structure can
actually change to accommodate different
linking modifications and so on and
we'll look at that a little bit more
detail - this is exemplified in this
slide where to the Left panel
again we show this similar view as you
saw before where we see the solvent
accessible surface I've sort of shown
more of the sava accessible surface the
region underneath the surface you can
see here to the right to the left in the
Left panel and now I'm showing to them
in the right pan on what we call the
exclusion Maps these are the regions of
the protein where the solutes or the
water molecules during our MV
simulations can never access they're
excluded from access
those regions and what this is doing is
this is giving us an idea of the full
range that the protein can open so if we
look to the maps the sovereign
accessible surface to the left then we
compare that to the right we can see how
much further back the exclusion map is
into this entire region which would be
essentially underneath the sovereign
accessible surface this can actually be
accessed when we're doing ligand design
so we can actually think it in terms
beyond going going beyond the protein
surface and we can judge this based on
the exclusion maps so in the end we were
actually doing our ligand design we
basically get rid of the protein
structure and we just work in the
context of our fragment maps and these
exclusion maps to allow us to think
about how to modify the ligand to create
modifications that will be synthetically
accessible and then to qualitatively
evaluate those modifications to
understand which of those will lead to
of improved binding and so on what's
also interesting about the silks
methodology is we include the water
molecules and that's important because
when you're doing ligand design there's
certain water molecules that were
binding to the protein and be very
difficult to displace and if you're
leading if you're trying to modify a
ligand to occupy a region where you
can't remove a water molecule that
legging won't bind well so what I'm
showing here is to the left of showing
in red spheres the position of water
molecules from a crystal structure and
then the red 3d maps are the positions
of water molecules from our silks MD
simulations and you can see in many
cases the crystal water molecules and
these maps correspond quite well but
what we really want to know is which of
these water molecules can our functional
groups compete with can they can they
remove allowing us to add those
functional groups to the protein
we get that information from the slide
on the right we're showing the same view
I still have the crystallographic water
molecules
I had the frying that maps associate
with the word molecules but then you can
see which of these water molecules also
overlap with different fragment maps
same with an aliphatic map we say a
positively charged map and this is
telling us which of these water
molecules functional groups can compete
with so we can add that functional group
we can confident that it will be able to
displace the water molecule and
therefore lead to improved binding
affinity in other cases you can see the
water private maps with no other map
there that indicates that these water
molecules will be difficult to this
place and again we don't want to try to
build our molecule out into that region
because the water molecule will be
unfavorable to displace that and
therefore our Lincoln would not find
well now those are some ideas of how we
can use the maps qualitatively we can
also use them quantitatively by burning
the silks frag maps from probability
distributions into we refer to as grid
free energies this is basically a
Boltzmann transformation of the
normalized probability distributions we
can also refer to as occupancy x' from
which we now obtain free energies and
once you've got these free energies we
can assign free energies to the
individual atoms in each molecule sum up
the group free energy contributions for
each atom in the molecule to get what we
call the ligand grid free energy and
this is actually a proxy for the binding
affinity of that Lincoln it's not
exactly the same as the experimental
binding affinity but we can use this to
rapidly calculate estimate the relative
binding affinity of different ligands
differently you modifications and so on
now once we're working in the context of
the grid free energies we can now start
to look at our fragment maps at
different and contour level
what I'm showing here are now aromatic
fried maps and contour levels of
negative point 5 negative 1.0 and
negative 1.5 and you can see as we go to
more favorable energies we focus in on
the regions where in this case an
aromatic group will bind most favorably
then as we go to less favorable and even
less favorable than maps spread out more
they're showing us the full range of
possible reasons where aromatic groups
can bind so we added our aromatic group
in the upper right panel to sort of that
region to the left we would still be I
have an improved binding affinity
although it would be much less than
improvement then in the region to the
lower right that we see at the bottom
and of the slide so now we can think in
terms of energies and this is very
important for the legging design because
we can now start to understand the
energetic contributions of the
individual atoms in each molecule and
here I'm showing a inhibitor genesis of
inhibitor of our p38 MAP kinase which is
overlaid on the fragment maps and then I
can understand the energetic
contributions of the different atoms in
the ligand to the overall binding
affinity sorry the font a little bit
small here but you see these the Central
Committee's own functional group the
free energy contributions are relatively
small whereas the free energy
contributions are much larger in the
vicinity say negative 2 indicating that
the overall contribution of say this
aromatic group is approaching a couple
kilocalories to the overall binding
affinity and so on also we can think in
quantitative terms where we see that the
different types of functional groups are
overlapping with the corresponding
fragment Maps we see the positive
fragment maps up here overlaying with a
positive functional group the automatic
and aliphatic Maps overloading with
these aromatic ring we see acceptor maps
which are overlaying with a fluorine
which acts as a hydrogen bond acceptor
down here we see acceptor Maps
overlaying with acceptors in this ring
system also we see that this amino group
is actually not overlaying with any
indicating that its contribution the
bonding is relatively small and then
importantly when we look at these maps
we see the maps beyond the molecule
itself and this is giving us information
on how to extend the molecule to
increase its binding affinity and so if
we look at the ring system up here we
can see adjacent to that are aliphatic
and aromatic laps as well as donor maps
this is indicating that maybe we can add
a aliphatic group which includes maybe
some type of a hydrogen bond donor may
have an alcohol and that would improve
the binding affinity so we can look at
these maps in a qualitative way as I've
been referring to to get some ideas of
the different types of modifications and
then because we working in the context
of these great free energies we can now
start to make quantitative estimations
of how the binding affinity changes and
so on
and once we now have these group free
energies as I referred to before we can
sum over all the grid free energies for
all the atoms in a molecule to get the
ligand grid free energy and here I'm
showing some thrombin inhibitors we have
some ligand grid free energies and we
can see how they correlate with the
actual known binding affinities of these
molecules and so on also once we've got
these grid free energies we can take our
molecule and we can use what we call
Monte Carlo sampling to to allow the
orientation of the molecule to relax in
the field of the fragment maps allowing
you to adjust its orientation and so on
and so this is a very powerful
technology to allow us to understand how
different types of modifications will
change the local conformation of the
ligand and this is important for
understanding how it finds and so on now
let's move to GPCRs now GPCRs g-protein
couple receptors are there's actually an
order of like
estimated about 3,000 GP different types
of GPC dollars in the body a large
number of drug molecules target gpcrs
there's a huge amount of effort on to
understand the GPCRs structure function
correspondingly to develop therapeutic
agents against GP cigars now what I'm
showing here is the actually the outside
edge of a GP CR and one of the
interesting things with GPCRs is
different types of molecules bind to
different regions of the gpcrs and this
is a challenge for computer-aided drug
design in general is identifying and
characterizing alternative binding sites
to gpcrs the typical binding site of a
GPC are where the ligand for that gpcr
say a safe dopamine to the dopamine
receptor binds is called the ortho
steric site we want to be able to
quantify nine or four steric binding
sites and I'm showing several of those
sites where on lipids or cholesterol
bind to the surface of the GPC are to
the left to the right this is where
polyethylene glycol peg binds the pocket
to the surface of the GPCRs this is one
of the challenges of computer aided drug
design for gpcrs now when we look at a
gpcr when showing to the left is a new
opioid GPCR and these protein coupled
receptors are made up of a series of
transmembrane helix so here's the
structure of the protein it would be in
a lipid bilayer would be surrounding
that protein and then the ligand for
this protein in this case a analgesic
agent referred to as bu 72 is binding
down deeply into the GPCR now if I take
this gpcr which I'm looking from the
side here and look from the top and I
look into edit what we call a solvent
accessible surface we can see that a
little bit of the binding site but that
binding site is very deep and it's
partially inaccessible and this is a
challenge to the soaps methodology
because we have to make sure that our
functional group maps are fried maps can
penetrate into that deep pocket to give
the information we need to do ligand
protein ligand design in the context of
GPCRs so the limitation of the social
methodology will initially developed it
was only using molecular dynamics
simulation was having our solute sample
into these deep inaccessible pockets and
when you're doing an MD simulation your
molecules are diffusing around in
solution in in two different binding
pockets out of the pockets and this rate
of diffusion is limited especially if
you have to move into a very deep pocket
in the protein and then move out again
and also we have to worry about big
conformational changes that need to
occur in a protein because our MD
simulations are limited in time such
that we've got to make sure that we
don't we're not limited by large
conformational changes in the protein
that can make the binding pockets a
inaccessible and while I'm focusing on
GPCRs today this type of problem is also
relevant for other types of proteins for
example these nuclear receptors I'm
showing a picture of the androgen
receptor here from the binary pockets of
the androgen receptor and other nuclear
receptors are totally blocked from the
protein surface such as a protein s to
partially unfold and again we wanted our
silks maps or fried maps to be able to
sample these very deep or totally
blocked binding pockets so we can use
the technology for GPCRs and other types
of proteins with these very deep
inaccessible pockets so what we
developed to do this was the the grand
canonical methodology and the grand
canonical methodology is in a well known
simulation methodology been known from
century or more but basically in this
methodology the trick here is instead of
just taking your simulation box and
fixing the number of atoms in there you
actually allow the number of atoms to
change and we call this constant
chemical potential so we can have
water molecules come into the box move
out of the box and so on and we can do
this in a way that corresponds to a
correct energetic in Samba or correct
thermodynamic example so we can get free
energy information in the context of
moving water molecules or solutes into
and out of the box and to think of the
GCM si methodology we call now grand
canonical Monte Carlo methodology we
think of our simulation system in this
case we've got a sphere we usually have
a rectangular type of system where we
have like a bath of say water molecules
and we can take those water molecules
and move them into the simulation system
or move them out and what we do is in
the grand canonical Monte Carlo
methodology we assign a chemical
potential in this case 5.94 water and if
you started to move the water molecules
in and out at equilibrium the
concentration of water would correspond
to 55 molar analogously if we had a box
of water and we took a solute say
benzene and we signed its chemical
potential to be correspond to that of
the strategy of salvation and we get our
grand canonical Monte Carlo simulation
the benzene our site would end up at a
concentration of about 1 molar in our
simulation system where this corresponds
to what's called the standard state
however it's been known that using this
grand canonical Monte Carlo methodology
is very difficult for molecules larger
than water and what we developed to deal
with this is what we call an oscillating
chemical potential where chemical
potential is indicated by Mui X grand
canonical Monte Carlo methodology and
basically if we have trouble moving a
solute into the simulation system we
basically just turn up the chemical
potential we give it more energy to do
that in essence this is rather technical
I won't go into more of the details here
I'll leave that for the reader there's
the relevant publication but this is not
only allow us this this is now allowing
us
to use this GCSE methodology to start to
sample these deep partially inaccessible
pockets in protein such as GPCRs to
extend our silks methodology to those
types of systems so we end up doing now
is we end up using the G CMC methodology
to sample the distribution of solute and
water throughout the entire simulation
system then we follow that with our
molecular dynamics simulations that
allows for conformational sampling of
the solutes entered around the protein
as well as for the conformational
sampling of the protein itself this is
important to remember as we talked about
earlier we want to see how the protein
can open to allow for understanding how
the protein can change its structure to
use that in drug design and so on and
then more again this is more technical
terms we use to the GC methodology for
say 200,000 steps we follow that with a
nanosecond of molecular dynamics
simulation and we repeat that typically
for like 100 iterations and we actually
do that for ten different simulations so
in the end we use our GCM CMV
methodology to perform about one
microsecond of molecular dynamic
simulation and again this is all pre
computation this pre-computation
typically takes in the order of a week
or two depending on the MD the size of
the MD simulation system the size of the
protein but then once this is done we
have our fragment maps and can now use
them over and over again in ligand
design and I'll go into some more
examples of that as we go through the
talk just a slide on validating the
methodology where we applied the method
to a protein called t for life design
which has a pocket which is totally
blocked from the surface of the protein
and what we can see here is that we have
a nice correlation between our ligand
grid free energies from the silk
methodology and the experimental binding
affinities and we see that with two
different approximations with respect to
how we calculate the liquid free
energies so again this is just
supporting
the quality of the methodology for
quantitatively predicting the relative
affinities of different ligands bound to
a protein so we get back to now our GPC
ours and here I now show the silk
simulation setup for the mule opioid
receptor you can see here's our gpcr
it's got these seven transmembrane helix
e's here's the extracellular face here's
the intracellular face our ligand binds
down in here
in the simulation system we also have
our lipid bilayer which in this case is
made up of popc along with cholesterol
molecules we have about 10% cholesterol
also you see the water molecules above
and below the protein and lipid bilayer
then in the water the water is shown in
red we have our different solutes which
are used to calculate the functional
group distributions or the fragment maps
so now we go back to our problems now we
can now show that we can apply the soaps
GCM CMV methodology to the opioid
receptor we can now look into the
binding pocket and you can see the
ligand but now we can see that the
ligand is encompassed in different types
of fragment maps showing that we've
effectively sampled different solutes
down in this deep pocket so we now have
the frag maps and we shown to the right
the frag maps actually overlaid on the
ligand from the crystal structure and
you can start to see how the different
types of fragments correspond to the
different functional groups you see both
acceptor and non-polar fragment maps
corresponding to this ring system to
this ring system the acceptor Maps
correspond to this oxygen as well as to
this hydroxyl up here we see positively
charged Maps corresponding to the
positively charged nitrogen which is it
typical in opioids and so on so now this
is the type of information which we can
start to use for both our qualitative
and a quantitative ligand design where
we can
understand how we can sort of extend the
molecule in these different directions
to improve its binding affinity these
types of things so we can now so this is
again just showing how we've extended
the selfs methodology to allow it to be
applicable to ligand design against
GPCRs in this case we're using the
opioid receptor as an example with
respect to identifying alternate binding
sites here are these sites on the
surface of the GPC are here is the
crystal structure of this polyethylene
glycol bound to the protein surface and
here we've got the fragment Maps
overlaid on the surface along with the
ligand and what you can see is how
nicely the fragment maps have identified
this period of binding pocket you can
see they also identify other types of
binding pockets on the protein surface
so the souks methodology just doesn't
focus in on in this case the ortho
static site associated with the idealist
binding but is basically mapping out all
possible binding sites in and around the
entire protein and this is very powerful
in the next slide we can show we show
the image of the the two lipids and the
cholesterol bound to the protein from
the crystal structure we can see how
nicely the fragment maps map out the
location of the lipids especially their
aliphatic hydrophobic tails and what was
interesting here is the fragment maps
did not identify the cholesterol binding
site but what was happening here was we
actually had cholesterol in the
simulation system and the cholesterol
went in and bound to this site and it
band there so tightly that the other
solutes can never compete with this and
this is suggesting that this cholesterol
molecule potentially has a functional
role in the biological activity of the
opioid receptors and this is just a
hypothesis based on the results from
these simulations but again because we
have the full simulation system with the
lipid bilayer the cholesterol we can
learn these types of make these
observations to allow us to sort of not
just do drug design but also to think
about how
GPCRs function and so on now I'm going
to follow these results based on the
amoeba opioid receptor with a study that
we've done on the beta-2 adrenergic
receptor which is again another gpcr on
this is an interesting system to apply
methodology because we have crystal
structures both in the presence of
agonists and in the presence of
antagonist so we have an active form
structure in an inactive form and with
GPCRs we know that there's
conformational changes that occur such
that the relative orientation of these
transmembrane helix is shift and these
control the active versus the inactive
state and so on
there's binding affinity for a large
number of ligands in the context of
therapeutics the beta-2 adrenergic
receptor is the target for agents for
the treatment of asthma such as I said
preparing all where if you an organized
the b2 adrenergic receptor
Melita bronchodilation however these
compounds which are out on the market
have problems associated with tolerance
and desensitization which motivates
identifying novel energy agonists that
will have lower tolerance this motivated
this therapeutic study so we went in
we're going to apply the silks
methodology again here's our simulation
system where we have our GPC are in the
center in green we have the lipid
bilayer with cholesterol we have the
water molecules and the solutes and the
top and the bottom
and for this particular system we
focused on the binding region for the
GCM C however we did MD in the entire
simulation system again we went in we
calculated our pre-computer in Samba
from which we've got the fragment maps
and then we started to use the fragment
match for our ligand design in the next
slide I'm showing the fragment maps
where we can see the fragment maps for
the active conformation of the protein
we can show the fragment maps for the
inactive conformation what we see here
is that they're significantly different
differences in the fragment maps in the
for the active conformation versus the
inactive conformation this is important
because we can now take the difference
between these maps to identify regions
where if we say occupy those regions
will have an agonist versus an
antagonist or vice versa so we can see
how by doing two sets of silk
simulations calculating two sets of
fragment maps the presence of again
these different confirmations we can get
differents maps which we can then use
for ligand design to specifically
designed agonists versus antagonist so
we can think of terms of activation as
well as improved binding affinity and so
on and this is quite useful in the
context of gpcrs to get agonist versus
antagonist
but we've also used it for different
types of proteins such as MCL one the
bcl-2 family proteins MTO one bcl-xl to
identify ligands say specific for one
protein versus the other protein or
begins it will bind to both proteins and
so on as an example of this has been
published a couple years ago male now
you can see again we visualize in the
maps of qualitatively you can see how
this facilitates your leg and design
quantitatively we can validate the
usefulness of the active map sources the
interactive maps or what we see is if we
take the active maps with a series of
agonist or partial agonist we get nice
correlation however we take the inactive
maps with the same series of agonists or
partial agonist we get much poorer
correlate correlations however if we
take inactive maps and with antagonists
or inverse agonists
we get good correlation however those
same excuse me antagonists are in an
inverse agonist with the
active massive poor correlation so this
idea of looking at different types of
fried maps for the active state and the
inactive state can be used
quantitatively as we're showing here as
well as qualitatively as we showed in
the previous slide and so on so what we
wanted to do here is come up with
totally new agonist of the beta-2
adrenergic receptor so what we did is we
apply what we call the silks pharmaco
for methodology where what we can do is
we can take the fragment maps and we can
convert them into pharmacal for features
and you see this would correspond to say
a positively charged maps hydrophobic
maps hydrogen bond donor maps and so on
and what we can do is we can then do a
database screen a computational database
screen to identify compounds that will
have the different structural features
which we've determined from the silks
fragment maps and then converted it into
what we call a farmer for now this
allows us to go in and screen this large
database in this case we screen a
database of about almost two million
compounds and from that we identified
the top fifty thousand compounds whose
structural features match that of the
farmer before at the different types of
hydrophobic groups are your bond donors
negatively charged and so on we then
took those top 50,000 compounds and then
we screen them in a couple steps
including using the ligand grid free
energies values from the soaps MC and
what we did here is we looked at the
energetic difference with respect to the
active form of the protein versus the
inactive form so we can then focus in on
going from say 50,000 molecules down to
a thousand molecules down to 100
molecules where we're now identifying
those molecules which will have a high
probability of binding to the receptor
but they will bind to the active form
versus the inactive form and then from
this hundred compounds we selected a
collection of 15 compounds based on
chemical features and what we want to do
in a drug design study at this point
maximizing chemical diversity because we
want new leads which are structurally
different than known compounds and so on
we then took those 15 compounds our
collaborators at Thomas Jefferson tested
those compounds and seven of our
compounds were actually agonists which
is a very good hit rate for these types
of virtual screening methodologies and
we can see the comparing those with the
compound isoproterenol which is a
therapeutic agent album on the market so
we move the study the methodology to
this point we have these compounds and
this is um we've had Lee just recently
got this study funded so we'll be able
to move this ahead in the near future
now what I also wanted to do with the
beta adrenergic receptor is show how we
can use the SS MVP methodology we're
going to go back to SS fep in a contact
of a GPCR so we're going to do here is a
generic receptors bind different types
of small molecules these biogenic amines
such as dopamine so we set up a model
calculation where we're going to take
dopamine we're going to bind it to the a
generic receptor and then we're going to
apply the SS SVP methodology and then
we're going to look at a large number of
modifications to identify those
modifications that are predicted to have
improved activity this is getting back
to the power of the SS FTP as well as
the souks methodology to calculate for
any differences of large numbers of
modifications and what we're seeing up
here on the dopamine molecule to the
right are all the different types we can
modify are the different sites in the
molecule we can modify at each of those
sites we're going to evaluate 43
different types of modifications of the
four to 30 types of modifications we
actually evaluated 410 modifications as
20 of those modifications were not
structurally suitable for the ligand
alone they're just the modifications for
too big
to give you an idea of the types of
chemical modifications I'm showing them
here you can see we typically suit the
SS FTP methodology we typically add
relatively small functional groups
halogens methyl groups fo groups
different types of polar groups and so
on but again the power of the
methodology is that we can go through we
can do our pre computed MD simulations
of the protein ligand complex as well as
the ligand in solution we can obtain our
pre-computer din samba we can then go
back and for the 400-plus modifications
rapidly calculate the change in the free
energy associated those modifications in
the presence of the protein as well as
in the presence of the ligand we then
get the change in the binding affinity
again this is based on the changes in
the free energy and the presence of the
protein and the absence and the absence
of the protein adjustable alone and we
now have hundreds of free energy
differences which typically can be
obtained on a overnight basis as we can
calculate the we do the pre computed in
sambal calculation typically on the
order of about 12 hours calculating all
the modifications takes another hour or
two and this is the power of the
methodology where we can take our GPCR
as I'm showing here we can put it into
the lipid bilayer surrounded by water
molecules we can do our pre computed MD
simulations and then we can rapidly
predict the change in the binding
affinity of large numbers of
modifications and so what I see here
ordem shown here in this slide is again
our dopamine molecule with all the sites
that we've modified ten sites in total
we're showing results for subsets of
those sites including both R and s
modifications you see this 582 5b
and what we see here is that many of the
sites all of the modifications are
unfavorable so those sites would be
indicated we don't want to do
modifications in those sites because
they're bad sites however in some sites
we do see favorable modifications and
those are the sites that we would like
to follow up on when we're actually
synthesizing molecules and doing testing
so you can see how we can use a
methodology to eliminate certain sites
from chemical modifications as well as
identify those types of those sites
which modifications are favored and then
we can actually go Elena we can say okay
we've got five favorable modifications
what all of those modifications what
actual chemical groups are they and
actually then go and synthesize and test
those and at the bottom here I'm showing
a table where we're showing that the
change of from dopamine to
norepinephrine experimentally leads to a
favorable change in binding and we get
that favorable change in the case of the
SSF repeat methodology the magnitude of
the change is not is not as large that
it's seen experimentally but typically
when we use the SS fep methodology or
the silks methodology we look at the
direction of the change is it more
favorable or is it less favorable
because that's this type of information
that say medicinal chemist wants to use
for making design and so on and in this
case with the beta adrenergic receptor I
focused on using the SFTP methodology we
can also use the silks methodology to
calculate the free energy change for
these large numbers of modifications in
a very analogous way some additional
validation we did with the SS fep where
we now started with epinephrine we took
effort effort in we then did
modifications of epinephrine to
norepinephrine or to dopamine and what
you see here is both of these
modifications are predicted to be
unfavorable and the SFTP methodology
correctly predicts those modifications
so indicating the validity of the
approach and again what we're focused on
is the direction of the fan
you change using that as the vehicle to
tell us what modifications to make or
not to make less on the actual
quantitative visit negative to
kilocalories is at negative 1
kilocalorie and so on now I just like to
point out a couple other studies that
we've done on gpcrs this is a silk based
study on the metabotropic glutamate
receptor subtype subtype 5m glo r5 we
did a structure-activity relationship on
a series of compounds we developed the
silks fried maps for the system this was
actually based on an apology model
before a crystal structure was available
you can see we have the silks frogmouth
which are synthetic collaborators were
able to use to guide their ligand design
we then get reasonable quantitative
predictability from the cad methodology
again this is just a study that there's
the reference but what was interesting
here is with our same collaborators we
were then able to perform a second study
on an entirely different series of
compounds but we ever use the same set
of fragment maps and then use those to
qualitatively drive ligand design and
then you can see the quantitative
predictability of the methodology and
what's important here is we did not have
to go back and recalculate the silk
fragment maps I just want to emphasize
again that once we've got these fragment
maps for a given protein we can use them
again and again for any lead compound
they do not have to be recalculated
again this is the general power of the
pre-computer approaches that we've
developed in the lab and are now
available to the scientific community
and so on and then finally I mentioned
before the siege NFF force field and
associated program which is important
because when we're doing the silks SSS
or SSS repeat methodology we have to
rapidly generate hundreds of thousands
of different types of ligands we need to
generate them in the computer decision
of F program
does that force very rapidly the quality
of the force field has been shown by a
number of workers in the field to be of
high quality of high accuracy and this
allows us to then quickly move in to do
a mated workflow of ligand design where
we can go in we can take our lead
compound we can go in we can specify
large numbers of modifications the user
typically can visualize say the fragment
maps in the context of silks identify a
number of possible modifications we then
generate all those modifications very
rapidly using the C gen FF technology
and then we go in and we do the silks
calculations and get through the LG fe
scores and we can literally calculate
thousands of tens of thousands of
modifications on a daily basis once
these silks frag maps are already in
place and again we can use the SSSP
methodology as an alternative i'd also
like to emphasize with the silks
methodology the value of the silks
methodology is we can study much larger
chemical modifications then we can with
SS fe p SS MVP's typically limited to
modifications of say two or three non
hydrogen atoms whereas the silks
methodology is you can look at very
large chemical modifications when you're
doing it linking design and so on so
just to finish up I would like to
acknowledge the people in my lab on
bunch of over month when Bo you call she
crying you lay Fang wen Jun Cano who
worked on the various necessary piece of
ethnology as well as the charm general
force field our collaborators on the
beta-adrenergic receptor up at thomas
jefferson lena her and deepak pentane
zoo and his lab members worked on the
unglue r receptor and then various
funding from the NIH NSF the Waxman
Foundation and then also my long support
by the University of Maryland School of
Pharmacy the University of Maryland
Baltimore computer-aided drug design
center and then silks bio LLC which is
now the commercial arm of the SSF VP
silks and CG nff technologies all right
thank you excellent thank you dr. McKray
for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question and drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for so let's get started with our first
question of the day our first question
asks what are the computational CPD
requirements for silts in the SFTP
methods
again it's the pre-computation that
takes the majority of the time the SS
fep method it's typically in the order
of 12 hours this can actually be much
shorter on the latest state-of-the-art
GPUs with the souks methodology the
pre-computation takes on the order of
three to four days for a relatively
small protein it may be up to two weeks
three weeks on very large proteins and
again we're doing ten simulations in
parallel but again it takes on the order
of weeks for the soaps methodology but
once we've got those finished we have
the pre-computer ensemble for both the
SS fep method and the social methodology
it takes in the order of minutes to
evaluate each individual modification
and this allows us to do thousands of
modifications very rapidly using the two
methodologies once the pre compute is
finished thank you no thank you
excellent thank you for answering that
question
our next question of the day asks what
information on the system of interest is
required to apply the stilts in the SSF
18 methods all you need is a protein
structure for majority of
therapeutically interesting proteins
protein structures are available from
x-ray crystallography or from NMR
spectroscopy if there's not a
three-dimensional structure in protein
available there's likely a structure of
a homologous proteins so homology
modeling can be used to determine a
three-dimensional structure which then
allows for the SSF EP or the silk
methodology to be used in the context a
specific ligand design it's often quite
helpful to have a crystal structure of
your ligand bound to the protein so you
know the bound orientation which will
facilitate just doing the modifications
with either soaps or the SFTP
methodology thank you okay and it looks
like we have time for one last question
today and this question asks what size
conformational
changes can occur in the protein during
the MV simulations the other simulations
are each simulations on the order of
about 100 nanoseconds so conformational
changes in the protein that occur on the
order of 3 4 5 angstroms can occur
during those simulations if there's a
very big confirmation will change such
as the change between the active and the
inactive confirmations of a GPC are
those will not occur in these
simulations accordingly what we've done
is we'll do individual calculations on
the active state and the inactive state
and then combine those together for the
ligand design on 4 agonist versus anti
yes as we showed based on the beta-2
adrenergic receptor thank you well thank
you dr. McKray for your presentation I'd
also like to thank labyrinth for making
today's educational webcast possible
before we go I'd like to let everyone
know that today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May of 2018 you will receive an email
from lab roots letting you know that
this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live events that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you here again soon at lab ruse
goodbye